utah very conservative state very very
conservative state they elected this
governor spencer cox
who in a in a zoom address that he was
just giving
announced his preferred pronouns
okay
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon i am
governor spencer cox and i have the
pleasure today of hosting the first one
utah student town hall and uh my
preferred pronouns are he him and his
he him and his
complain again just play it again please
okay
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon i am
governor spencer cox and i have the
pleasure today of hosting the first one
utah student town hall and my preferred
pronouns are he him and his
whatever political team that guy's on
i'm not on it i don't know if that guy
is what a republican is i guess i'm not
a republican i i here's my ideology you
know i generally don't like idiot my
ideology is whatever he's not
because that is the saddest thing i have
ever seen
and
i guess he thinks he's pandering to
students i guess he thinks that students
really believe in all this stuff who
knows maybe they do not the conservative
students i talk to and i talk to
thousands of them a year
spoke to some last night right here in
grove city pennsylvania so i'm speaking
to some on monday at yale university
that should be interesting i spoke to
some last week at washburn i go around
to a lot of these schools
we don't introduce our preferred
pronouns some people will say who cares
who cares spencer spencer cox he'll cut
taxes or regulations so he's a perfectly
fine chamber of commerce republican i
care i care that's it that's my line i'm
all for a big tent party
if you
if you use your preferred pronouns if
you introduce yourself stating your
preferred pronouns you're out you're out
i think he should be kicked out of the
republican party he should he should he
has no place here because it means i'm
not even just being hyperbolic and
reacting emotionally what it means is
you don't get anything you just don't
understand anything
if you are willing to cave on
men or not women if you're willing to
cave on a most a fundamental aspect of
human nature then you're just completely
useless i don't elect a democrat utah i
don't who cares
you're just tot you just don't get
anything so spencer cox
you're out you're out of my when i
become the head of the republican
national committee you're gone i'm
taking away your republican card you
always hear this phrase today follow the
science well probably the most
anti-science movement in the country is
abortion
it just doesn't make sense it is
biologically and bioethically completely
indefensible which is why you got to
check out our friends over at 40 days
for life they have the number two amazon
christian bestseller the book is what to
say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion how to change minds
and win hearts in a brave new world
40 days for life is based in texas they
are one of the largest pro-life
organizations out there it's really
important to know the arguments what to
say when abortion is about to become a
huge issue because of the supreme
court's decision
coming up that could overturn roe versus
wait we've seen one of the grisliest
mass murders in american history
involving an abortionist in d.c get the
arguments right now they've got a
million volunteers in a thousand cities
holding peaceful 40-day vigils outside
of abortion facilities to save lives and
help abortion workers leave their jobs
get the book what to say when right now
head on over to
40daysforlife.com to check it out
did you like that clip i'm glad go
subscribe ring the bell get the
notifications also head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify or stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]